dozens of you sent me this clip that
we're going to look at um congresswoman
debbie lesko who's a republican i
probably didn't have to tell you that
you could probably figure it out from
what she said she's from arizona she
said on the floor of the house of
representatives that she would do
anything for her own grandchildren
including shooting them
what what does that even mean now did
she just miss speak
well if she did she hasn't clarified it
she's responded to criticism of this
bizarre statement by saying people are
attacking her and all these different
if she misspoke she could just say she's
misspoke but let's take a look at what
she said arizona is recognized for two
minutes
thank you representative jordan i rise
in opposition to h.r
2377. oh i have five grandchildren
i would do anything
anything to protect my five
grandchildren including
as a last resort shooting them if i had
to to protect the lives of my
grandchildren
have we really gone so woke that a
god-fearing flag-waving republican can't
shoot her own grandchildren to save them
what on earth does this mean like if
they're about to shoot themselves dead
she would shoot them in the hand so they
drop the gun
and don't kill themselves like what what
does it even mean what possible scenario
would this even be an option
and the scenario i'm landing on
is she seems very unstable and should
probably have guns taken away it sounds
like she's very very dangerous now what
was her response to this lesko responded
by attacking so-called gun control
zealots
for suggesting she would shoot her own
grandchildren but that's exactly what
she said
instead of attacking the people saying
what the hell is she talking about as
zealots she could just say oh i misspoke
i did say i would shoot my grandchildren
but that's not what i meant
oh all right well that's simple newsweek
reports that debbie lescoe suggested her
critics are misrepresenting her comments
well i just played it for you
we we could listen to it one more time
it was very clearly recognized for two
minutes
thank you representative jordan i rise
in opposition to h.r
2377. okay i have five grandchildren i
have five grandchildren
i would do anything anything to protect
my five grandchildren she would do
anything to protect her grandchildren
including as a last resort shooting them
including as a last resort shooting them
now is there some other noun in the
sentence that she might be referring to
when she says them no the only noun she
has talked about
is her grandchildren so why can't she
just say i misspoke
i said in my in my zealous
defense of my own grandchildren i
misspoke what i meant was
i would even go so far as to shoot an
intruder
in order to save my grandchildren why
can't you just say that is it this is
the trumpian influence she says
something bonkers it might be as simple
as she misspoke
and her response is to attack so-called
gun control
zealots for going after her
um
i guess this is part of the whole
trumpian thing where you can't apologize
anymore or you can't just say i i just
said the wrong thing i misspoke you
can't do it anymore so she just has to
attack people bizarre stuff i hope
somebody has checked but just to be safe
i hope someone has checked on her five
grandchildren one of our sponsors is
magic spoon the only breakfast cereal
that tastes exactly like your favorite
sugary childhood cereals but with zero
sugar only four net carbs and 14 grams
of protein so if you're just generally
trying to keep your sugar intake
relatively low like me or if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto you
can enjoy the sweet nostalgic snack
without the sugar in flavors like cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cookies and
cream maple waffle blueberry cinnamon
they've just added honey nut to their
permanent collection i love magic spoon
our whole team does and they've been
supporting the show for years how about
this if you try magic spoon and you
don't think it's amazing like we do
they'll give you your money back because
magic spoon stands behind their product
because it's that good you really can't
tell it apart from the classic cereals
build your own custom variety pack
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is in the description